dude if there was real chaos people
would do pretty much anything to survive
yeah anything
and they're going to come to you and say
we will destroy you first the first
thing will say look if you're if you're
in these areas you most likely agree
already they don't need to convince you
to anything they're going to be like the
crazy Trump conspiracy theorists who
think lizard people control the world
are coming we need you to stop them and
the people are going to believe it
they're going to turn on CNN and CNN's
going to tell them what to do and
they're going to say okay look if you
you tell me you don't believe me take a
look at Texas where you've got adult
entertainers dancing for babies and
children with a big neon signs and it's
not going to lick itself and the cops
going uh listen I can't get involved
here
they're not they're not going to defy
these factions even if the law is on
their side they will not do it they will
do what they're told as per the cult